hi there
you know i've been in in la viv now for
i guess i arrived on
on monday
and today is thursday
and i have never been in a place quite
like this
it is
everyone should come here it's a
phenomenal place it's
there's street musicians everywhere
there's people everywhere
there's churches there's old buildings
there's the neatest restaurants where
for like
anywhere from
five six seven eight ten
max fifteen dollars you have a fabulous
meal with a glass of wine or two
in behind me is the building where my
little apartment is located that i have
rented for
two weeks
fabulous little apartment clean
bed kitchen
and what i've been doing here is a sort
of an experiment
in language learning where i have hooked
up with a line with teacher
and every day i have six hours with her
but not six hours in a classroom
i meet her and we go somewhere we have
visited monasteries churches
um
sat in cafes
um
gosh i can't remember we different
places and she's very good at
maintaining the conversation so we talk
about history we talk about language
learning we talk about different aspects
of the ukrainian language my original
intention
was to study russian and ukrainian and
possibly polish i was quite ambitious
but when you're in levive you're just
going to study ukrainian and what i'm
doing with link she sends me this is the
other thing as i walk around with my
tutor solomia
she has her iphone with her android or
whatever it is and she types in all the
words and phrases that i'm having
trouble with and as soon as i get back
to my room i get an email from her with
20 phrases which i then import in the
link and study but what i am also doing
is
setting my dictionary language at link
to russian
so then i say phrases and i then save
the russian meaning for them so that i'm
sort of working on my slavic languages
through ukrainian
and and sort of confronting the russian
equivalent so that it doesn't interfere
i know what it is this is ukrainian this
is russian i may maybe next week start
doing it into polish i don't know
anyway i'm just so much more confident
with my ukrainian the first night i was
here i had trouble ordering my meal
and i just had a meal now and i had the
great discussion with the waitress and
ukrainian felt very very good about it i
went to a little fitness club that i
found
drop-in cost is four dollars
for another four dollars you get a
trainer but i didn't get the trainer
because i hadn't booked it i haven't
booked a trainer i was going to book a
trainer just to have more ukrainian
practice but everything was fine in
ukrainian so i'm really i really feel
that i'm making great progress
six hours a day
and a follow-up review of my of my
phrases and words and link and stuff and
so by the time i'm done like i've got
another
of six hours a day
i have say friday saturday monday that's
three more days i'm halfway through that
this lady just walks by and smiles at me
feels that she's interrupting my video
um
and then i'm gonna stay on and do
another i was gonna travel but i just
want to really
elevate the level of my ukrainian i'm
enjoying it so much
and just out of interest this morning um
solomia took me to a what they call the
coffee mine here where these there's a
group of people who have a series of
restaurants themed restaurants one of
them is a coffee mine and it talks about
how
the underground in la viv consists of
coffee beans that are mined
and it's just a riot and it's a little
restaurant cafe
and it has a lot of different sort of
mining type
paraphernalia which
you know around the idea that somehow
coffee is mined and stuff it's a lot of
fun and then she took me to this secret
place
where
uh it's sort of like done up in this as
a sort of a
hidden
uh
headquarters for the ukrainian
freedom fighters who
fought basically against the soviet
union
uh
against
the germans although it's it's quite
controversial because it was part of the
sort of nationalism of the 30s and there
were certainly some pretty
horrendous acts of violence committed
primarily against polls however the
polls are not without blame either
because
they tried to suppress the religion and
and the nationality of this of the
ukrainians i mean it was a time of
pretty serious
conflict between different people
be that as it may
you walk in the door and it's a secret
place so it's not marked but
people know where it is and then a
fellow shows up answers the door
uh with a machine gun
and he says uh what's that what's the
password and the password is
which means you know
glory to your green and then he gives me
this little drink
and he's got his machine done
and he said something and i didn't quite
hear what he said except that with the
words muscale was there mosca which is a
sort of a derogatory term for russians
moskowit moscowitz
i thought that that was the drink he had
given me like a misca day or something i
don't know what he put in his
i said yes stuck so then he shoots off
his machine gun
bam
and then uh solomia explained what the
situation was and i said no no i just no
i'm not i'm mosca okay here you go so
that was kind of an example of where you
uh you got to be a little careful with
your language but it's all done with a
lot of humor however i i appreciate the
fact that it's quite controversial
but uh you know that's where i am this
is this is livy uh one of these days i'm
gonna they have a a jewish restaurant
and i went there to look at the menu and
the menu has no prices on it
and the waiter says
we don't have prices we negotiate
so i'm going to wait until i get a
better sense of what prices should be
and my ukrainian improves then i'm going
to go there it's a galician restaurant
we're in galicia here
uh halle chana
and i'm going to try some of their food
and negotiate the price at any rate i'm
having a blast and it's unlike any place
it's less expensive people are friendly
people are in the streets all the time
and it's it's another world it's not
it's not
berlin
paris
london
it's it's something else
i i recommend people visit levi okay bye
for now
[Music]
you